eine ziemlich gefährliche mückenart die
ist jetzt in deutschland aufgetaucht
welches ist und wie man sie erkennt und
was dann getan werden sollte jetzt in
klick zum seitenwechsel
die ams albopictus gehört zu den drei
gefährlichsten mückenarten der ganzen
welt sie ist circa zwei bis zehn
millimeter groß sticht nicht nur nachts
kann erreger wie beispielsweise den des
dengue-fiebers oder auch das gelbfieber
oder auch den erreger des schinken gunia
fiebers übertragen
auf deutsch heißt sie asiatische
tigermücke so entfernt der name der
mücke klingt so nah ist sie uns auch
schon in deutschland eigentlich ist sie
in süd und südostasien zu hause doch
wissenschaftler fanden einige exemplare
der asiatischen tigermücke in
deutschland ähnlich wie exotische
pflanzen andere heimische pflanzen
gefährdet gefährdet die asiatische
tigermücke uns
wir kennen das alle abends im bett diese
summen im ohr der kurzen schreckmoment
wer das oben aufhört wenn die mittel
gelandet ist und dann das heftige um
sich schlagen um die mücke zu verjagen
neben dem zahnarztbohrer ist das summen
der mücke wohl eines der unangenehmsten
geräusche warum schlagen wir um uns zum
einen wollen wir das nervtötende
geräuschlos werden und zum anderen
wollen wir nicht gestochen werden falls
wir doch gestochen werden müssen wir uns
auf einen eine angeschwollenen juckende
haut region einstellen und wenn es
allergien gibt also wenn man allergisch
auf die stiche reagiert das sieht das
noch heftiger aus und noch schlimmer
sieht es aus oder kann es aussehen wenn
man von der ahé des albopictus gestochen
wird
der schlichte asiatischen tigermücke
unterscheidet sich erstmal nicht
besonders stark von dem stich einer
normalen stechmücke der schmerz etwas
und das war es vorerst vorerst deswegen
da die tigermücke die eine oder andere
krankheit übertragen kann zitat das
typische an der tigermücke ist dass sie
gern mehrere menschen hintereinander
sticht dadurch kann sie zu beträge von
krankheitserregern werden so die
biologin doreen werner vom leibniz
zentrum für agrarlandschaftsforschung in
müncheberg damit der einordnung können
welche auswirkungen der erreger haben
kann also die erreger die übertragen
werden erst vor zehn jahren brachte das
chikungunya-fieber 200 menschen auf der
insel la réunion den tod in etwa 270.000
menschen wurden angesteckt ein kleiner
überblick der symptome muskelschmerzen
lymphknotenschwellung punktförmige haut
blutung magen-darm-beschwerden und sehr
hohes fieber
in deutschland in der nähe von freiburg
wurden jetzt von der kommunalen
aktionsgemeinschaft zur bekämpfung der
stechmücken mehrere asiatische
tigermücke nerven gefunden zitat wir
haben intensiv dort besucht wo viele
lastwagen aus italien ankommen und sind
fündig geworden berichtete der
wissenschaftliche direktor der caps
norbert becker was haben die lkws aus
italien damit zu tun man geht davon aus
dass die tigermücken so nach deutschland
gekommen sind in den 90er jahren seien
sie mit einem frachter nach italien
gelangt dort angekommen sind diese
sozusagen auf den warentransport via lkw
umgestiegen dass sie es bis nach
deutschland geschafft haben ist für
viele wissenschaftler besorgniserregend
und bedarf sofortige gegenmaßnahmen
bisher sehen diese so haus info material
wie beispielsweise plakate und so weiter
und infoveranstaltungen die caps gibt
auch ein insektizid heraus dass
biologische insektizid bti ist tötet
mückenlarven ab zitat unser ziel ist es
im herbst so wenig weibchen wie möglich
zu haben so der biologe ator ist von der
caps
kommen wir zu dem punkt wie erkennt man
die asiatische tigermücke und was mache
ich wenn ich eine solche entdeckt habe
also zwei bis zehn millimeter ist sie
groß angesagt und besonders auffällig
ist ihre färbung die hinterbeine sind
schwarz weiß gestreift und ihr kopf ist
mit einem silber weißen strich verziert
dies natürlich schwierig weil der größe
zu erkennen wenn ihr aber eine solche
entdeckt nicht ärgern oder versuchen sie
mit der hand zu treffen was dann ihr
könnt versuchen sie zu fangen und da
zwar gibt es dafür spezielle insekten
gläser wenn ihr eine solche asiatische
tigermücke gefangen habt könnt ihr euch
auf www mücken atlas de informieren
wie er weiter vorgehen könnte hinter der
seite stehen unter anderem forscher des
leibniz zentrums für
agrarlandschaftsforschung und des
friedrich-loeffler-instituts sie
untersuchen eingeschickte mücken und
ergänzen die verbreitungsrate auf mücken
hat was.de der link ist natürlich unten
in der video beschreibung eine
erfreuliche nachricht zum ende in
deutschland seien die mediziner egba
training vom bernhard-nocht-institut bei
untersuchten tigermücken bisher
keinerlei tropische viren gefunden
worden
eine weitere erfreuliche nachricht
konnte vor kurzem un generalsekretär ban
ki moon verkünden genau das erfahrt ihr
hier oben im verlinkten video zu rap und
zum doc kommt ihr hier unten und
schreibt uns doch mal in die kommentare
welche erfahrungen er schon mit mücken
gemacht habt habt ihr eine allergie
gegen diese habt ihr mal so richtig
fetten mückenstich gehabt oder habt ihr
vielleicht schon mal tropische insekten
angetroffen auf eurer auf lasst es uns
wissen und bis dann bleib dran